Let's go through it. If you had a regular expression like a+,
I could rewrite that as aa*, so I never actually need plus. It's just convenient.
There is no regular expression for a^n. There is.
It is a+, and this recognizes a, aa, aaa, so this is misleading.
However, for this one, there is no regular expression for a^n b^n.
This is the same as the language of balanced parentheses
except we're using a's in b's instead of open and close parenthesis.
There is no such regular expression. We need a context-free grammar.
Finally, every regular expression has an associated finite state machine
that recognizes the same strings--yep--and we saw a little bit of how to do this.